FAMILY TONIGHT, HERE'S TUCKER.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT," YOU
THINK HOUSE OF CARDS IS A TV
SHOW, SORT OF, ALSO KIND OF REAL
AS IT TURNS OUT.
TODAY THE FBI BROUGHT CHARGES
AGAINST A FORMER DIRECTOR OF
SECURITY FOR THE SENATE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE, THE MAN
IN QUESTION IS CALLED JAMES
WOLF.
IF HE WAS IN CHARGE OF HANDLING
INFORMATION AS IT PASSED FROM
THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH TO THE
CONGRESS.
HE HAD ACCESS TO HUGE AMOUNTS OF
HIGHLY CLASSIFIED INFORMATION
INCLUDING INTELLIGENT DOCUMENTS.
A JOB LIKE THAT REQUIRES
UNIMPEACHABLE INTEGRITY, HE IS
ACCUSED OF LEAKING CLASSIFIED
MATERIAL TO SEVERAL REPORTERS
AND THEN LYING ABOUT IT TO THE
FBI AND GETS WEIRDER FROM THERE.
ALLEGEDLY HE PASSED INFORMATION
TO A COLLEGE STUDENT CALLED
ALLIE WATKINS, SHE WENT ON TO
BECOME A REPORTER IN SEVERAL
MEDIA OUTLETS INCLUDING
POLITICO, BUZZFEED, AND
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" ."
HE ADMITTED HAVING A
RELATIONSHIP THAT WENT ON FOR
THREE YEARS, WATKINS HAS DENIED
THAT WOLF WILL SEPARATE SOURCE
FOR HER STORIES BUT TEXT
MESSAGES STRONGLY SUGGEST
OTHERWISE.
HERE'S ONE.
I ALWAYS TRIED TO GIVE YOU AS
MUCH INFORMATION SO YOU COULD
GET THAT SCOOP BEFORE ANYONE
ELSE.
I FELT LIKE I WAS PART OF YOUR
EXCITEMENT AND WAS ALWAYS VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF YOUR CAREER AND
THE TENACITY YOU EXHIBITED TO
CHASE DOWN A GOOD STORY.
IT GOES ON LIKE THIS.
IT'S PRETTY SAD AND A LITTLE
CREEPY, I FELT LIKE I WAS PART
OF YOUR EXCITEMENT?
YOU IMAGINE THESE GUYS ARE
SINISTER, TURNS OUT THEY'RE
MOSTLY JUST PATHETIC.
THERE ARE TOO.
IF THE RUSSIA HOAX DIDN'T EXIST,
CORRUPT BUREAUCRATS WHEN TO BE
MISUSING THEIR POWER WHICH THEY
ARE.
IT'S HARD TO FEEL TOO MUCH
SYMPATHY FOR THIS GUY.
THE FEDS ARE ONCE AGAIN
PROSECUTING SOMEBODY WHOSE SOLE
ALLEGED CRIME IS LYING TO THE
FEDS.
IT WOULD BE NICE IF OUR
GOVERNMENT WENT AFTER PEOPLE FOR
REAL CRIMES, IT MIGHT MAKE YOU
FEEL BETTER ABOUT THE SYSTEM.
THE DOJ ALSO SEIZED PHONE AND
EMAIL RECORDS FROM A REPORTER
ABOUT THIS CASE AND BROKE INTO
THE ENCRYPTED TEXT EXCHANGES, I
DIDN'T KNOW THAT WAS POSSIBLE
TURNS OUT IT IS.
IT LOOKS A LOT LIKE WHAT THE
OBAMA PEOPLE USED TO DO.
IT WAS WORRISOME THEN AND IT'S
WORRISOME NOW, WHEN THE
GOVERNMENT SPIES ON AMERICAN
CITIZENS IT IS ALWAYS A BIG DEAL
WHETHER THOSE CITIZENS ARE
"NEW YORK TIMES" REPORTERS OR
TRUMPED CAMPAIGN STAFFERS IT
DOESN'T MATTER.
THERE HAD BETTER BE A VERY GOOD
REASON FOR SPYING ON AMERICANS.
THE MEDIA DON'T RECOGNIZE THIS
THEY ONLY CARE IF SOMEONE SHARES
THEIR POLITICS.
AS FAR AS THEY ARE CONCERNED
CONSERVATIVES WHO ARE WIRETAPPED
BECAUSE THEY ARE CONSERVATIVE.
THE PRESS WOULDN'T KNOW A
PRINCIPAL IF IT GOT IN THE
SHOWER WITH THEM BUT THE POINT
REMAINS.
DAN BONGINO JOINED US TONIGHT,
SINCE I KNOW YOU FOLLOW THIS
STORY PUT THIS IN CONTEXT FOR
US.
HOW DOES THIS WOLF CHARACTER FIT
INTO THE LARGER STORY?
>> THE NAME OF CARTER PAGE, HE
WAS RELATIVELY ANONYMOUS IN THIS
SCHEME.
CARTER PAGE HAD ASSISTED THE FBI
IN A PRIOR CASE WHERE THEY
LOCKED UP A RUSSIAN SPY, THE
NAME WAS RELATIVELY UNKNOWN AT
THAT POINT.
WOLFE IS THE ONE WHO LEAKS THE
EXISTENCE OF THE NAME TO ALI
WATKIN'S WHO THEN WRITES THIS
STORY.
THIS IS WHERE IT GETS UGLY.
THIS IS WHY THE PRESS HAS ZERO
THAT STORY BY WATKINS IS CITED
REPEATEDLY TO ADVANCE THE MEDIA
PROPAGANDA STORY THAT TRUMP IS
COOPERATING WITH THE RUSSIANS
BECAUSE CARTER PAGE NOW THAT
THEY HAVE THE NAME WAS A TRUMP
FOREIGN POLICY ADVISOR.
THIS WAS USED OVER AND OVER
AGAIN.
THIS IS THE CIRCLE OF LIES AND
DECEIT WE SEE.
I AGREE WITH YOU, YOUR OPENING
STATEMENT IS SPOT ON.
I HAVE A LIBERTARIAN SPINE I
DON'T CARE WHO WAS IN OFFICE I
AM ALWAYS CONCERNED ABOUT THE
FREEDOM OF THE PRESS.
PERIOD.
IF WHAT I FIND HYPOCRITICAL IS
THE PHONIES COMPLAINING NOW
ABOUT A GOVERNMENT OVERREACH
WHILE YOU BEND DEAD SILENT ON
SPYING, ON THE PROSECUTION OF
MIKE FLYNN, GIVE ME A BREAK.
YOU FORFEITED YOUR VOICE TO TALK
A LONG TIME AGO.
>> Tucker: IT WASN'T SPYING,
REMEMBER THAT WHEN A PAID
GOVERNMENT INFORMANT GATHERED
INFORMATION SECRETLY ON THREE
SEPARATE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
OFFICIALS AND SEND IT BACK TO
THE GOVERNMENT, THAT WAS THE FBI
DOING ITS DUTY.
>> I WATCHED YOUR INTERVIEW WITH
ERIC SWALWELL THE CONGRESSMAN
FROM CALIFORNIA WHEN YOU
MENTIONED A SPYING HE SAID
SOMETHING THAT WAS TRUE TO YOU.
HE'S NOT HERE TO DEFEND HIMSELF
BUT HE SAID WE ONLY SPY ON THE
BAD GUYS, HE WAS RIGHT!
TRUMP WAS THE ENEMY, THIS IS THE
NEW LIBERAL POLICE MIND-SET.
TRUMP IS THE ENEMY, NOT THE
CHINESE, NOT THE RUSSIANS THE
REAL ENEMY WAS DONALD TRUMP.
HE WAS ABSOLUTELY RIGHT, THIS IS
THE NEW LIBERAL MIND-SET, HE IS
THE BAD GUY.
AS LONG AS YOU'RE SPYING ON
CONSERVATIVES IT'S OKAY AND WE
WILL PLAY THE EUPHEMISM.
HE WAS AN INFORMANT, HE WAS A
SPY AND EVERYBODY KNOWS THAT.
>> Tucker: WE USED TO HAVE
TRIALS THAT HELPED US UNDERSTAND
WHO WAS THE BAD GUY.
PEOPLE WERE ACCUSED OF THINGS
BUT NOW THE ACCUSATION IS ITSELF
CONSIDERED PROOF OF GUILT.
WHEN DID THAT HAPPEN?
>> I'M GLAD YOU BROUGHT THIS UP,
THIS IS WHAT FREQUENTLY GETS
LOST.
CARTER PAGE IS THE ENTRY POINT
FOR THE SIGNALS INTELLIGENCE
SPYING OPERATION, THE
INTERCEPTION OF THE EMAILS INTO
THE TRUMP TEAM.
NOBODY HAS PROVIDED A SCINTILLA
OF EVIDENCE THAT THERE WAS
PROBABLE CAUSE OF THE TWO THINGS
THEY NEEDED TO SPY ON CARTER
PAGE.
SECONDLY IN VIOLATION OF U.S.
LAW, NOBODY HAS SHOWN THAT
CARTER PAGE IS OUTDOING CABLE
INTERVIEWS PROBABLY TONIGHT
SOMEWHERE.
THIS IS NONSENSE.
>> Tucker: IF CARTER PAGE WAS
GUILTY, WHY HASN'T HE BEEN
CHARGED?
HIS BEHAVIOR WAS THE PRETEXT FOR
THIS ENTIRE STORY, DOES IT TELL
YOU SOMETHING THAT HE HASN'T
BEEN CREDIBLY ACCUSED OF A CRIME
BEEN CREDIBLY ACCUSED OF A CRIM
CRIME?
>> THE FBI AND DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE WALKED INTO A FOREIGN
INTELLIGENCE SURVEILLANCE COURT,
USED EFFECTIVELY THE STAR
CHAMBER, USED TO PROSECUTE THE
WORST AMONG US, THE WORKS OF
SAVAGES ON THE PLANET.
THEY BRING CARTER PAGE IN THERE
TO SPY ON HIM AND YOU'RE RIGHT,
HE'S OUT WALKING AROUND RIGHT
NOW.
THE FBI ISN'T INTERVIEWING HIM,
I KNOW OF NO CONTROLS ON HIS
BEHAVIOR AT ALL.
THE ANSWER IS BECAUSE THERE
PROBABLY IS NO INDICATION OF
CRIMINAL BEHAVIOR AT ALL AND
THEY DESPERATELY WANT THAT ANGLE
OF HIM TO GO AWAY.
>> Tucker: ONCE YOU TALK TO
CARTER PAGE YOU REALIZE HOW SAD
THIS WHOLE THING IS.
HE WAS NEVER A RUSSIAN AGENT OR